two weeks ago every Zionist account on
social media every Zionist media member
was writing articles hysterically from
here to Australia saying can is having a
mental breakdown K is unhinged K is
angry writing lies about
me just imagine the people back in the
day when they would have to travel
certain distances for months or even
years what is one thing that they would
carry with them the Quran why because
they did not have it on their mobile
devices or their gadgets brothers and
sisters imagine you have a app the Quran
app which not only shows you how much
rewards you get but reminds you to read
the Quran gives you reminders download
the Quran app now and let it testify for
you on that you read it wherever you was
we was expecting this to happen Zan yeah
we was expecting it after hearing all
the information we was expecting that to
happen I know you're thinking about
something else but I'm talking about
Candace Owens ah ah nice but surely this
only happens to Muslims brown people and
extremists that are a danger to society
surely it wouldn't happened to
Christians and people that are you know
rightwing or people that you know have
ingratiated in society Alie I like that
word ingratiated nice intiated what
ingratiated ingratiated what does that
mean yes nice okay guys so alhamdulillah
as you can see that Candice Owens is
starting to make her way towards being
cancelled why though did she say
something what happened to freedom of
speech I mean the fire right supporters
tell her if Tommy would support her and
say you have a right to freedom of
speech you know cuz it's the Muslims
that you can't talk about no it was all
a big fat lie this is lying this you
cannot talk about that's correct there
is no freedom of speech and like Candace
Owen says with her own mouth it's after
October 7th things changed a paradigm
shift Happ brother and sisters why cuz
it was a big fat light under the
pretense of freedom of speech and
democracy and no no no no no no no when
you say big fat lie so your words don't
get misconstrued what was the big fat
lie n ah nice so we're going to react to
four or five Clips this one is the main
one but she's expressing and sing us
inah why she's sing us for you know one
thing I'm no about anytime she say
Israel have you know she goes Israel why
she yeah she goes because Israel she I
don't pay attention that much I do the
opposite agenda Ali nice okay let's
react to this first clip of she explain
to us why she got canceled and it gets
really interesting as you guys watch it
please watch the whole five Clips in
they're not that long this one is the
longest nothing on my account other than
the day that that account awesome Jew
began publishing a step-by-step guide
for how people could Mass report my
Tristan Tate interview when my Tristan
Tate interviewed aired and YouTube
actually responded on Twitter and said
that these sort of Target harass
campaigns wouldn't work and then lo and
behold they quite literally took down
that video and we then filed an appeal
we haven't actually heard back on that
appeal but I kind of put it in the back
of my mind and interestingly enough like
it's kind of been a journey with this
and I did kind of expect this to happen
especially after the rabi debate I knew
there would be some price that I had to
pay for it because you just can't have a
video or a debate go that Viral and I
could just see how angry the Zionist
Community was about it and you could
sense their anger also in their silence
which is so interesting just to weigh
against two weeks ago every Zionist
account on social media every Zionist
media member was writing articles to
hysterically from here to Australia
saying cace Owens is having a mental
breakdown cens is unhinged cace Owens is
angry writing lies about me and yet
absolute crickets if you go online right
now and you type in like Rabbi Shi
canone despite the fact that it was
trending for two and a half days on
Twitter not a single article was written
which was negative about Rabbi Shi and
it sort of has been like a build with
like throughout I would say the last
year really almost exactly a year I
think sort of post October 7th for
better or worse things have changed
we're not going back to the place the
America the Conservative Republican
movement whatever you want to call it
that we were prior to October 7th um and
I think it caused a lot of people to see
the world through a different lens and
to see a lot of people who they had
trusted and who they thought were
morally consistent not live up to that
expectation and so I knew like when the
first kind of harassment campaign came
and it was essentially like this is what
your opinion has to be on this situation
and I didn't bite on that I knew what
the consequence was going to be
obviously everybody saw the writing on
the wall it was like we will come for
your job and you will no longer have the
platform that you do but I really did
have the confidence like when all that
happened this year I I knew that I would
be fine because I very much believe in
myself and I think that that kind of
comes from a I think the public trusts
me we've been through enough together
with you know the medell
a okay so you see her basically clearly
saying that after the of October things
change for the whole world and I'll be
honest with you it really is I mean it
we are in a time of History where you
know to the the the zionists have been
using this argument of the Holocaust and
all this kind of stuff not to be
criticized and the battery is running
out why because they are hijacking that
to say that you cannot criticize in any
way shape or form even if that means
that we are doing evil so much so she
said that she even lost her job and I
know this speculation on The Daily while
she left come on bro if you're
relationship yeah and you're with an
abusive person a person who's evil
you're either leaving that relationship
willingly or unwillingly yes okay you're
going to be forced to leave and that's
what happened with her her saying oh no
I chose to no you didn't you was forced
to leave the D daily wire she lost her
job that's number one who's Tad hicky so
Tad hickey amongst many other people is
in fact Tad hickey all he's known for on
Twitter his Clips go viral where he's
just doing sketches and uh little um
kind of satirical
um poking fun at Israel poking fun at
others as well but you know given what's
going on poking fun at Israel and he's
been demonetized as well there you go um
and he's received a strike also what
Israel Israel criticizing Israel in fact
being called and he says this is in no
way what he's done and people can watch
his content called a Hamas glorifier or
Defender or whatever it is Richard medur
who's a Christian from um I think the
Middle East but again light-skinned a
journalist whose parents I think have
won the Nobel Prize Nobel Peace Prize
his dad was a police officer but yet he
got an invasive search as well and you
know um he got asked a lot of questions
you know there's there's so many and
Candice Owens to join the ranks on
YouTube because YouTube used to be a
platform that was somewhat a bit more
kind of um logical not like meta yeah
meta's been open yeah with regards to
its bias but YouTube why do you think
that is I mean YouTube I don't know
actually I'll be honest with you YouTube
has been quite consistent in the sense
where they don't literally get rid of it
they can demonetize you but they let you
on there I've been I've been seeing
YouTube bit more uh tolerant when it
comes to freedom of speech more but now
this is how we're starting to see the
shift why do you think that is well
before we come to that let's watch the
other three four Clips they're short and
let's get some more context inah and
also being very much aware of the fact
that no matter what you think about him
RAB Shi has power he has never lost any
of his positions he's allowed to write
for I think it's the Jerusalem Post that
he writes for he is invited into those
circles you heard him speaking about how
he's friends of be and Yahoo and how
Israel has nukes and how he has access
to all of these people that are
extremely powerful and they've never
distanced him they've never called him
on hinge they've never called him crazy
I knew that I was standing up to to real
power and I knew that again I would have
to face some sort of a consequence for
just really allowing Rabbi to expose
himself like there wasn't really much
done by me other than to point to the
world that this is radical and the
people that are telling you that I'm
being hateful are boldly lying and I I I
truly mean it when I say I'm grateful to
RAB Shi for That interview I'm grateful
for the way in which he lies and just
has zero apprehension about it like it's
just a part of his nature I'm grateful
for all of that because people got to
see that live like how someone can just
literally say this woman got up on stage
and like supports Adolf Hitler and we
didn't cancel heart knowing fully well
that that's a lie doing it because you
are trying to destroy somebody's
character and for the world to go
through that and for me to have received
all of the emails that I did with people
saying you know that was the first time
that I understood what you have been
trying to communicate this very bold and
this very brave of her to know and do
that and step up that and you need to
give give credit to her because you know
why she is speaking up against Injustice
and this is an A in the Quran you know
if K is watching this you know speak the
truth even it's against yourself man if
whoever it is for that matter and she's
literally doing that she knows that this
guy is boasted you know in his CL with
Benjamin Netanyahu and he's got friends
in this place and that place Etc you
know they're making it very very bold
but she said I don't care she's going to
speak out against and she's going to
remember in history for that just a few
other clips that she mentioned I just
quickly want to watch the harassment
campaign doesn't work then we're going
to have to get her deplatformed and
that's what you're seeing is just a a
very pattern really with with zus I
would say I mean this is the sort of
stuff when you see that aranel writes a
letter and says no one can work for no
one should work for Kane anymore what is
that really what is that shouldn't we be
able to decide whether or not we want to
buy his shoes and you could say listen
I'm not Adidas has a right to fire
whoever they want to D has a a right to
fire whoever they want to but when all
that comes on the heels of one person
writing a letter these are the kinds of
questions that I think we have a right
to start asking and when somebody openly
says like this account we're going to
harass her so she has no platform and
she can't make any money what they're
saying is okay so when it comes to
controlling like when is quite
controversial controlling the media
would we say I mean I think I would say
it's maybe a bit farfetch to say oh Jews
control the media but to say zionists I
mean do we have any evidence of them
controlling the media because it's
becoming more and more apparent that
anyone speaking against Israel or
Zionism for that matter is you know
somehow losing being demonetized
deplatformed I don't
[Music]
know
uh all all those notes you've been
writing all right so you know don't
carry books you don't want to be one of
those want to be a donkey you don't want
to be a
mgar so ad ADL who ADL no ADL nice yeah
they've been designated as a trusted
Flagger okay on YouTube yeah so a ADL
are the Anti-Defamation League and um
they've been described as an Israeli
intelligence asset why so well even the
FBI I think it was in
1960 they tried to make them classed as
a foreign agent because they were
collecting information on Palestinians
that were in America they were
collecting information from them and
sending it to who oh mosad to India
close okay mosad all right okay yeah
yeah yeah nice so that's the ADL they're
The Trusted flaggers that are in YouTube
but when you make statements like does
so and so control this or control that
that's not our place to say however we
can just present the facts and you can
come up with your own conclusion it's
literally as simple as that so you've
got ADL a very powerful and influential
organization and then let's look at the
individuals that work in YouTube and
their positions so YouTube streaming's
Global head of Music in 2016 was
somebody called Leo Cohen yeah and Leo
Cohen was once described as the tall
Israeli who runs the rap industry oh
okay yeah to such a degree that this guy
he he got uh certain artists music
either removed or them removed and some
of those artists were Lup Fiasco he was
one of them Professor Griff and even low
Key's music was suffering a lot on
YouTube as well okay is it any surprise
because these artists spoke against
Israel they were political and this guy
got involved so you're being
anti-semitic now you're trying to say
he's he's controlling the rappers no
what I'm saying is that this was uh I
mean he had a house in a settlement an
Israeli settlement okay his family have
relations with the Israeli terror group
called hagana oh really yeah so so this
is this is Leo Cohen who's been um given
such head of Music in in YouTube 2016
the marketing chief of YouTube Ricky
drory he served in the Israeli
occupation forces yeah and Neta Neta
gross she was uh high ranking she had a
high ranking role she's gross she
definitely is gross after you find out
that she she had a high ranking role at
Google and YouTube but she also served
in the Israeli occupation forces as a
satellite officer yeah that's definitely
gross yeah that's definitely gross yeah
and lastly not to mention actually
there's two more n Citron uh who was the
YouTube product strategy lead and she
used to be the int Israeli intelligence
operative and you had draw Orin that's d
r o r Orin who was a senior product
director at YouTube and also served for
the Israeli occupation forces so these
are very high ranking positions that
have been offered to let's face it
criminals offer to I don't know if
there's an offer I think there's a
direct thing so if it sounds like a duck
and it looks like a duck then it's an
elephant it's a quack
quack last video sh off
uh canand this this is a long it
wouldn't require a circle of journalists
a circle of zionists to keep embarking
on these sorts of harassment campaigns
it would be so obvious that this was the
right thing to support that you wouldn't
have to threaten Financial terrorism to
get the public on your side and that's
where we are now you probably see that
I'm pretty chill about this the reason
is I don't know I I think partially it's
because H to support evil there there is
no circumstance in the entire world
financial terrorism I don't I don't
worship Mammon you know that I will be
compelled to subject myself to evil to
submit myself to evil and I see that
many people have made that decision many
people who I came up in politics with
and I understand it and to an extent I
have compassion for people who think
okay well this is just one topic that I
don't have to touch and I can still I
can support my family I I I'll just
avoid talking about this topic alt
together I'll pretend that Gaza doesn't
look like Dres in times 10 and that this
is totally normal and turn the other
cheek and to those people I just I guess
what I really want to say it's just I
don't know if that excuse is going to
work in the only court that really
matters and that's a court of God and
it's very interesting she said if the if
the cause was just they wouldn't need to
do all these threats they wouldn't need
to do all of this stuff their cause is
not just very good point and and that is
so profound as you can see and you know
what this is happen Allah subhana tala
you know even though she's a a Christian
again you know she is speaking the truth
and you know Allah tells in the Quran
that the people of the book are not the
same you know and you can clearly see
that you know there are Christians who
come to speak as Corner outright
supporting Zionist and then you've got
Christians like her who are standing up
for justice who are if they are
following following the true way of
Jesus and the biblical teachings but hey
it's the Muslims that are taking over
the UK and America yes it's the Muslims
that you need to have a ban for like
Donald Trump's calling for because
apparently we're the ones that are sens
are we the ones censoring and removing
people from platforms and curtailing
their freedom of speech I don't think so
I mean you cannot make this up bro like
Allah has made things work in such a
magnificent way Subhan Allah even the
atrocities that carried and may Allah
accept them all as martys by the way the
whole world like in a matter of under
one year shifted W let me tell you
something you cannot make this up and if
they gave us billions and trillions of
pounds to or orchestrate this to show
the real face of Zionist we would have
not been able to do it they done it free
of charge with their own mouths genocide
in a hd4 like Lally literally 4K bro
you're watching it happen and the entire
world is now seeing the reality and that
they used Muslims to see see us as the
evil guys the whole world is now waking
up and you know when someone is told a
lie if I was to tell you this person is
evil and and I portrayed him in a
certain way I wouldn't believe you good
you wouldn't but imagine you believe me
and then you found out the reality bro
you are your cause and your ambition is
going to be far greater because you're
going to say you lied to me all this
time and I thought he was the evil guy
where it was you and that's what's
happening with the people they're like
you've lied to us for so many years over
20 30 years and vilifying Muslims and
all along yes hypocrisy freedom of
speech all of this human democracy
whatever you want to call Human Rights
you guys went against every single thing
you believe I think they are the true
margarites they are margarett if you
want to know what Margaret means please
search it it's a Bosnian you why are you
spoiling Theo all right you are a just
say margarett then they're going to be
like why do they keep mentioning that in
all these videos exactly and holy you
are a Margaret yes this you're a
Margaret all you people who are
committing atrocities who hating on me
Mett till next
time to all the margarites